Thanks, Paul.
The combination of strong execution and a strengthening market led to exceptional financial results.
Better-than-expected demand in the microprocessor and chipset businesses...
...led to the largest sequential third quarter revenue growth in over 30 years.
Gross margin percent at 58% was up nearly seven points from the second quarter.
Operating profit was up 80% and net income was up 77%...
...excluding the impact of the 1.45 billion-dollar EC fine taken in the second quarter.
The PC market segment is recovering nicely...
...with our microprocessor revenue excluding Atom growing 23% since the market bottomed in the first quarter.
In the same time period, Atom microprocessors and associated chipsets...
...have grown to 450 million dollars in revenue in the third quarter...
...and one billion dollars year-to-date.
Gross margin benefited from exceptional execution in the third quarter.
We responded to our customers' upside requests and achieved a significant reduction in costs...
...resulting in a 58% gross margin, a nearly seven-point increase from the third quarter.